♪♪
Narrator: A COMPUTER PROGRAM
GUIDES A PLASMA TORCH
TO CUT OUT PRECISELY SIZED SLOTS
IN A SHEET OF HIGH-GRADE STEEL.
THE SLOTS WILL HOUSE
THE ILLUMINATED NUMERALS
AND INDICATORS LIKE ARROWS.
A WORKER THEN FEEDS
NARROWER STRIPS OF STEEL
TO A PRESS THAT BENDS BACK
THE EDGES TO CREATE TABS.
THESE STRIPS WILL SERVE
AS THE SIDES OF THE SCOREBOARD,
AND THE TABS WILL BE USED
TO INSTALL THEM.
HE FASTENS FOUR STRIPS
TO THE BACK PANEL.
HE THEN ATTACHES
THE PLASMA-CUT FRONT PANEL
TO COMPLETE THE BASIC STRUCTURE
OF THE SCOREBOARD.
THE NEXT WORKER
SPRAYS A POWDER-PAINT COATING
ONTO THE ENTIRE SCOREBOARD.
THEN IT'S INTO
A GIANT CONVECTION OVEN
FOR ABOUT 14 MINUTES
TO CURE THE POWDER PAINT.
THE RESULT
IS A TOUGH POWDER-PAINT SKIN
THAT WILL MAKE IT POSSIBLE
FOR THE SCOREBOARD METAL
TO WEATHER THE ELEMENTS.
THEY ARE NOW READY
FOR WORKING PARTS
LIKE L.E.D.
LIGHT-STUDDED DIGIT BOARDS,
A DATA TRANSMITTER,
AND RECEIVER.
HE CONNECTS THE RECEIVER
TO THE POWER SOURCE
AND INSTALLS IT
INSIDE THE CABINET.
THERE ARE SEVERAL LIGHT-STUDDED
DIGIT PLATES ON A SCOREBOARD.
EACH CAN FLASH ANY NUMBER.
HE WIRES THEM IN A LOOP,
INTERCONNECTING THEM
IN WHAT'S KNOWN
AS A DAISY-CHAIN CONFIGURATION.
HE ALSO PLUGS IN
A RIBBON-STYLE CABLE TO LINK
THE DIGITS TO THE SCOREBOARD'S
PROCESSING MODULE.
HE INSERTS THE DIGITS
IN THE SLOTS ON THE FRONT
AND SHIELDS THEM WITH A SHEET
OF TRANSPARENT POLYCARBONATE.
HE CONFIRMS
THAT THE WIRING IS GOOD
AND THAT ALL THE NUMBERS
LIGHT UP.
HE CONNECTS THE WIRELESS
COMPUTER PROCESSING MODULE
TO THE NUMBERS AND ALSO WIRES IT
TO A POWER SOURCE.
HE MOUNTS THE MODULE TO A PANEL
THAT WILL THEN BE INSTALLED
THROUGH THE BACK
OF THE SCOREBOARD CABINET.
WITH ALL THE LETTERING
NOW IN PLACE,
THE NUMBERS ON THE BOARD
WILL MEAN SOMETHING
TO THE CROWDS IN THE STANDS.